merci mon avis la parole est à monsieur
georges fenech
oui monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
le garde des sceaux mise la justice un
policier de 36 ans père de famille est
entre la vie et la mort après avoir été
grièvement blessé par deux malfaiteurs
lors d'une course poursuite
le groupe public un tiens à rendre
hommage aux forces de l'ordre qui paient
un lourd tribut
la lutte contre la délinquance madame la
ministre nous apprenons avec
stupéfaction que l'un des deux
malfaiteurs qui a succombé à ses
blessures avait bénéficié d'une
permission de sortie en mai dernier puis
qu'il avait été fiché s en voie de
radicalisation et qu'il était en fuite
la colère des forces de police et
l'incompréhension des français est
d'autant plus grande que ce père
missionnaire affichait son casier
judiciaire pas moins d'une trentaine de
condamnations notamment pour des faits
de vol à main armé violences volontaires
associant malfaiteurs madame la ministre
elles créditent la justice qui est en
jeu aujourd'hui
vous ne pouvez éternellement esquivé
votre responsabilité en vous abritant
derrière l'indépendance des juges
la politique pénale est de votre
responsabilité
les juges en l'espèce ne font
qu'appliquer les lois or force est de
constater que depuis votre arrivée place
vendôme
vous n'avez eu de cesse de déconstruire
le système répressif et favoriser les
sorties prématurées de prison et cerise
sur le gâteau madame la munition
permettez l'expression
vous nous promettez maintenant la
suppression des tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineurs et l'abrogation de la
rétention de sûreté pour les criminels
dangereux
le résultat d'autres politiques eh bien
nous la connaissons depuis hier puisque
le mist d'intérieur a publié les
chiffres qui sont à la hausse les
chiffres de la délinquance
alors ma question est simple quand allez
vous remettre vous remettre en cause
madame la ministre ait écouté les
français déboussolés et exaspérés par
votre laxisme
merci monsieur fenech la parole tarab la
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
le seul président mesdames et messieurs
les députés monsieur le député georges
fenech
ce policier de la bac père d'un jeune
enfant se bat encore pour rester parmi
nous et nous pouvons tous ici et
ailleurs
imaginez la détresse de sa famille et
les squares qui résiste encore
nous pouvons aussi comprendre angoisses
de ses collègues et même entendre la
colère qui peut les saisir et ce drame
nous rappelle simplement douloureusement
que les lez nition d'exercice du
maintien de l'ordre s'exécute toujours
avec des risques concernant le tireur
concernant le tireur il était
effectivement considérés comme état
d'évasion en état d'évasion depuis fin
mai 2015
parce qu'il n'avait pas réintégré la
détention à la suite d'une permission
qui lui avait été octroyé par un juge
d'application des peines pour exécuter
des formalités administratives à la
suite du décès récent de son père
l'administration pénitentiaire a
immédiatement informé le parquet de
melun qui a aussitôt décidé de saisir la
police judiciaire et non pas seulement
de prévenir le commissariat local et
d'émettre un mandat d'arrêt
monsieur le député je crois que la
circonstance ne permet pas de politique
une polémique parce qu'il n'ya pas que
il n'est pas question d'aménagement de
peine que ce détenu avait aurait dû
sortir de prison en janvier 2018 il n'y
a donc pas d'aménagements de peine mais
par contre je comprends les
interrogations et c'est pour ça que
daisy hier j'ai commandé un rapport
précis sur ce qui a pu se passer
depuis que le procureur de la république
a ouvert cette enquête en mai 2015 sur
la recherche ce détenu est par ailleurs
monsieur le député les textes sur
lesquels sont fondées notamment cette
décision d'octroi de
permission de sortie n'ont pas été
modifiés depuis 2004 et nous nous
étudions justement la possibilité de les
améliorer et notamment d'imposer une
escorte pour certains détenus pour ce
type de motif de sortie
merci